and I'll be speaking about our own homegrown Sensor 5 Car 5.
These are my disclosures.
Why pick CD5?
So we decided to target CD5 because it is expressed
on the majority of the nodal T-cell lymphomas
we see here in North America.
So well over 80% of all T-follicular helper
and peripheral T-cell lymphoma, NOS, do express CD5.
And if it is expressed, it's usually very strongly expressed.
So Dr. Ruella in his lab designed a single chain variable
antibody targeting with high affinity to CD5
and created a chimeric antigen receptor
that's 4,1-Bb co-stimulated.
So as we've heard already very elegantly in the talk before,
there are a lot of unique challenges
in developing CAR-T-cell products in T-cell malignancies.
And one of course is the fratricide
and the other one is the carcinogen.
And one of course is the carcinogen.
And one of course is the carcinogen. And the other one is that we do kill healthy T-cells.
And while one can survive without B-cells, you can't really survive without T-cells.
So we decided to approach this issue by knocking down CD5.
And we were able to knock it out effectively in well over 97% of the cells,
and then transduce the CAR5 into the cells.
And what we observed, more or less,
And what we observed, more or less, incidentally, is that actually by knocking out CD5,
And what we observed, more or less, incidentally, is that actually by knocking out CD5, we created a very effective product
Additionally, we created a very effective product
And that is why CD5 is the most effective product